hi Jeffrey thank you so much for joining
me today
I wanted to ask you how do you feel
about being back over the board and
playing in this event chess line Alex
yeah I'm absolutely thrilled to be back
in St Louis the weather is phenomenal
um
and yeah I had a long break but I was
still training in chess so hopefully
I'll be ready to go you're spending some
time streaming as well right
yeah there was a period where I streamed
a bit just to see how it was I stopped
momentarily but I might presume it at
some point
I wanted to ask you how much time do you
did you spend to prepare for for the
event was there something in particular
that you did to get ready for chess 960.
yeah I started preparing about a month
before the event just mainly training
playing training games getting a feel
for all the different setups
and yeah kind of just sparring sparring
with someone and
did you use the same time control as the
event I played shorter variants like
five plus five and ten plus five just to
mimic the increment but also
um having a shorter temperature to train
being more decisive
what do you think is a good exercise
to improve your someone's visualization
in chess
it's a tough question
um I would say
maybe just plain blindfold chess could
help so that you can memorize where the
pieces are going and as as you're moving
them
what do you think is more important in
chess 960. I would actually go with
um just knowing where the pieces belong
because they're scrambled at the start
so you have to sort of figure out
how to place them in
a non-traditional way
and I think if you are able to sort of
get the pieces out you know control the
center get castled everything then the
game will go your way
do you prefer classical chess
I think my fear was always rapid sort of
in the middle not too fast not too slow
and
there's definitely a lot of excitement
you can still get the time scrambles but
there's still time to think
um you will have 15 minutes
um once the position will be revealed to
you you'll have 15 minutes to prepare
for your next round how important are
those 15 minutes in order to get ready
for your next game very important I
think it'll be difficult to sort of
predict because there are so many
opening moves like even at the beginning
you'll have moves like G3 or B4
F4 some kind of moves that are not
typical in traditional chess but are
playable in chess 960 depending on the
position so
um most importantly I think is
getting the pieces out and cats knowing
where to Castle I think and then you can
go from there
are you stressed at all about the event
do you feel any pressure oh no not at
all I think it'll just be a really fun
event just 960 so it's unrated so that
really takes the pressure off all the
players and I think it'll be a really
nice event
foreign
[Music]